may I first of all remind you of some of
the domestic arrangements the WCS are
situated outside the meeting room
outside the council chamber opposite the
chairs a cold water is also available in
the breakout area outside of the council
chamber if the fire alarm should sound
can you please leave the meeting room by
following the fire exit signs and can we
meet on the Ipswich Town Football Club
training pitch please do not re-enter
the building until we are told it is
safe to do so
can I ask everyone please just to
double-check your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off and as we know if
they ring it's a donation to the charity
I would like to remind everyone present
this meeting we broadcast live by the
internet and will be capable of repeated
viewing the whole of the meeting will be
filmed except where there are
confidential or exempt items if you make
a representation to the meeting you'll
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being filmed and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and/or trading
purposes the council members of the
public and press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded finally can members
and officers please ensure that you do
press the microphone when you speak and
turn off when you finish please
just some introductions or as we have
two members the public present just in
case you're not aware of who will do
what today in front of myself I'm
councillor Matthew Hicks and my
colleagues on my right here at the front
bro we are the district councillors
who'll make a decision on the
applications before us today in mid
Suffolk district council if there is an
application within your own Ward you may
not vote therefore you have to cross the
trailer and sit on this side where we
have a another councillor present you'll
be able to speak on an application in
their ward but as I said not vote on the
far right we have in depress who's our
legal advisor and we have general Walker
who's the area planning manager
and we have very support officers and
officers who present them they'll be
introduced as they present the various
the two applications before us today so
I think that's dealing with all the
technicalities and when you do come up
to speak if you've come to the front row
and you will have three minutes and we
have an egg time here and we do keep the
three minutes please
so if first item on the agenda is
apologies for absence and substitutions
do we have any place
do we need to receive any declarations
of pecuniary or non peculiar interest by
members council even Thank You chair I'd
like to make an non pecuniary interest
for item 7b I appreciate that this item
is just a variation of conditions to do
with colleges and garages but due to my
mother living dead opposite sides and
being an objector I think it'd be better
that I don't take part that I've make a
non canary interest declaration and I
don't take part in the vote for that
Thank You chairman councilor eben didn't
kindly warn me of this and I'm quite
satisfied it's a non-pecuniary interest
of the accounts level has decided it
would be best if she doesn't vote on
this item so if you're not going to vote
I would suggest it's probably best not
to take part in two debates as well so
you leave after the first item okay
thank you very much any other
decorations of interest by members no
thank you very much next item is any
decorations of lobbying by members path
Robeson County burn on that item at home
yeah
okay thank you very much any
declarations of personal site visit by
members your your fine with that as a
ward member you would have you would
have done that that's fine yeah thank
you very much
item number five is confirmation in the
midst of us held on the twenty fourth of
july 2019 these are in your papers pages
1 to 12 i just run through them quickly
and if you have any points that you want
to clarify them you need looking at just
raise your hand when you can't each page
our papers page 1 2 3 4 & 5 6 & 7 8 & 9
10 11
can I sign this as a true record of the
meeting it's at agreed agreed
thank you after meeting okay so back to
the agenda the next item is schedule of
planning applications the first item is
DC 1901 5 5 8 the bungalow I'm very
sorry item number 6 received
notification of petitions in the course
of the council's petition scheme do we
have in it we do okay one petition has
been received regarding the first
application that members will be looking
at today and the petition summary reads
as follows to consider the attached
petition signed by 47 residents of thorn
and magna objecting to application
number DC 1901 5 5 8 for the
construction of a bridge to provide
vehicular access to the bungalow the
street
Thor non-magnetized Suffolk IP 23 8 HB
when deciding the outcome of this
application thank you thank you so that
petitioners received and mated so thank
you very much
okay so now we move on to the shredder
the planning applications and the first
one is DC 1901 five five eight the
bungalow and the street corner Magna
near I and who will be presenting thank
you very much
somatic have Yanni on one of the
planning officers here the proposal is
for a bridge to provide a vehicle access
to de bungalow in fauna Magna as you can
see here is the site location plan
showing the location of the application
site within the village this also shows
some constraints on site we have a few
great T listed buildings nearby also
there's a group TPO to the north and the
application site is partially situated
within the special landscape area
heritage team were consulted and they
haven't raised any objections to the
proposal this is a flood map showing the
application sizes again partially
situated within the flood zone two and
three the smallest stream water water
course is in fact River dove but when he
comes arrive at the village to the north
it becomes a small watercourses stream
extensive f ra was submitted as part of
the application and also the
government's flood risk information
identifies the risk in this locality as
medium meaning the each year it has a
chance of flooding between 1 percent to
three point three percent our flood
officer was also consulted and he hasn't
raised any objections to the proposal
here's just the wider context of decide
the nearest sesamum Andrea's thorn him
poverty' north this is another aerial
photography show in a position of the
site application site and also some
landscape qualities that sorta surround
the site this is the red line boundary
showing the site and the scale of the
site this slide shows the location of
the site and the proposal as well as the
trees and vegetations on site it is
worth noting that previously in 2006 an
application was approved for a bridge
for the book house the current proposal
proposes to have access to the bungalow
and a Brooke Houston North although they
prove all was over ten years ago I
thought he was worth noting that there
has been an approval on site currently
there was an access to dabangg below as
a footpath a footbridge vehicle access
is to the north some distance away that
serves the book house and if you are the
properties there is currently no direct
access to the bungalow order book house
this engineering drawing shows the
extent of the construction as well as
the materials proposed and the
dimensions and it is in accordance with
good design the proposed bridge would
not act as a barrier according to this
drawing in case of flooding or in case
of passage for the water species that
reside in the stream there are similar
examples of the bridge not exactly the
same but similar examples that can be
observed up and down the street on this
side this is again further details of
the drawing showing the technical
engineering details
this is slide shows the extent of their
trees and the hedges to be removed from
the side which is less than 10 meters to
achieve visibilities place access and
visibility displays as part of the
application the applicant submitted
ecological report which identifies there
are no protected species on site no
nesting birds amphibians or any other
protected species also this shows the
level of impact upon the street scene in
terms of landscape qualities and it is
considered minimal these are some images
that were taken from the site on-site
with it the top one on the corner right
corner shows the footbridge currently on
site left image is the bungalow itself
and there is some street scene along
this street some further images
recommendation form offices is for
approval as detailed within the report
thank you very much thank you very much
do we have any questions at this point
yeah counselor burn first thank you sure
um thank you for that could you tell me
how far the access the road access to
the north is from the proposed access
please in meters thank you
in terms of metric measurements I
haven't measured it but it's about three
sides to the top and the sites within
the streets are especially in this part
of this street quite generous I generous
I so so I'm just going to go back to the
slides
sorry bear with me so the accesses to
the farmhouse didn't North as you can
see is it is it visible as I said I
haven't measured it in metric measures
so I'm not quite sure the exact
measurements of it but if that's
something that the council's wish me to
do that's something that we could about
it's not a scale because then the excuse
me
we'll get someone to bring that up the
actual scale of drawing and then we can
measure it rather than taking it off our
drawings here which obviously gone from
eight five days before I was at a three
day four anyway but to be more accurate
counsellor Manso thank you
could you please indicate with a pointer
or something on the aerial photograph of
the site the existing vehicular and
pedestrian accesses to the bungalow and
the has just to the north of the
bungalow place preferably on the aerial
photograph would you be able to see it
from there
see it's here the current the current
axis is there it's not homogeneous now
[Music]
there's an axis however because of the
mature trees and hedges on site you
won't be able to it's it's here can you
can you indicate with that with that
mouse thing the pointer as if you were
driving from the road to the bungalow
how would you get there so you would to
start from wherever you start for
example from here let's go up and you
get there's an access here at some point
nearby so didn't you drive back down and
then you get to the bungalow you also
indicate on that on that aerial
photograph where the pedestrian accesses
yes there is a footbridge right opposite
the bungalow which is here a couple of
things just to make that clear you're
saying there's essentially a private
track through the property's adjacent to
the bungalow on their side of the
watercourse that's right there's a
there's a passage there's a footpath the
input from the parish council I think it
was rather concerned about the number of
trees that would be removed to make the
visibility splays wasn't totally clear
to me with their comments are correct or
not does the visibility's display
require significant trimming back of the
edges or not they have to submit it an
extensive agricultural report indicating
that there's going to be removal of
hedges and trees for about less than ten
meters to achieve visibilities place and
access and also the report that they
have submitted shows the route
protection area and it also demonstrates
that that won't be touched as part of
the proposal however to have assurances
and an interest of community of the
neighbors and the street we could
propose conditions landscape conditions
for up to five years to ensure that
whatever is lost could be replanted okay
so essentially the parish comments that
there will be 90 meters of demolition of
the existing vegetation is not right
thank you
but one other point you mentioned that
there are no species in existence on
this plot and any place I find it a bit
difficult to believe that there are no
species in the protection whatsoever in
an age of that size are you confident
that the report is correct the the
report has been submitted to us is in
accordance with British standards so yes
we will accept that as that and also
what that we received shows the measures
that can be imposed during before during
and after the construction to ensure
that there will be no danger to the
species or any nesting birds or
amphibians that might exist there but at
the moment is medium- that's the term
that they used in the report any other
questions
at this point yeah custom mayor can you
confirm that there is already a bridge
of a similar construction on on the road
yes in terms of exactly engineering
details I won't be able to as a planner
and what we have to assess yes there are
similar bridges are on the street thank
you any other questions
nope okay so we'll move on so we now
move on to the parish council first of
all and we have Jennifer Balder if you'd
like to come up and we have the timer
here
sit please do sit and if you can push
the the silver button with the map with
the face on it okay thank you
good morning members as an appointed
officer I'm here to speak on behalf of
thorn and magnet parish meeting as I
hope you already appreciate thorn and
magma have a unique and to date largely
unsupported Kaptur the line through the
center of the village is charming with
no footpath flanked by much treasured
narrow River and historic Konza or
walkway bordered by listed buildings
residents enjoy this character who do
not wish to see it spoiled by the
introduction of this large and unsightly
concrete monstrosity there is an
overwhelming opposition to this proposal
from the village which in 24 hours 47
villages of our population of 210 to
signed a petition against we firmly
believe that the erosion of this special
character should not be allowed the
bridge is simply not necessary as there
is already an access bridge to the
bungalow rather it is a speculative
developer's desire in order to maximize
a profit as part of the likely
redevelopment of the bungalow site the
proposal is not innocuous it would
impact Heth very heavily on the street
and also the Konza this proposal will
introduce neither access at the
narrowest point of the street where two
cars can barely pass and it will be
dangerous and will result in the loss of
90 metres of significant mature greenery
habitats and character which could
contribute strongly to our lovely
village in a very recent inspectors
report in firmly dismissing an appeal
for seven new houses houses a stone's
throw away from this site the inspector
said the concert is softened and
screened by a largely unbroken belt of
landscaping that contributes
significantly to the street scene and
the local distinctive quaint and rural
character of the settlement this setting
is special please Ben allow it to be
sparked with this insensitive thirteen
point five meter long industrial
concrete structure that is inevitably
designed to support a subsequent
proposal for additional dwellings on the
bungalow cyant this may be the tip of
the iceberg but irrespective this is
damaging enough in its own right and
with impact and the
it will have the village does not need
or want this inappropriate and
unnecessary bridge we urge you to reject
this ill-conceived and unsympathetic
blight that a remote an opportunity to
stick developer is seeking to impose
upon us in the centre of our village
thank you for your time thank you very
much and do we have any questions they
would have been submitted they have to
be submitted before the meeting oh not
rather brought to the meeting so through
when you when you put in your responses
from the parish that's really the time
to submit those sorts of things
yes customer you talked about 90 metres
of trees but we've been told that only
ten would be removed well the display of
the bridge is thirteen point five meters
so that's more than ten isn't it yep you
talk with 90 meter it is not a 90 meter
strip yes I saw a chair I'm confused
it's not ten meters we've been told that
ten meters will be removed and then
we've heard that 90 meters are gonna be
ruined but I just like to understand how
many trees are gonna be removed so we
just had some clarity that the parish
meeting is saying there's 90 meters of
hedgerow being impacted and you're
saying this 10 meters Garuda's have
clarity as to what what the figure is
because if display is 13 meters is 10
meters accurate I believe that the
parish responded with regards to Suffolk
Park in the standards and visibility
splays I believe that's the figure came
from that document because no in the
submitted documents there has been any
mention of 90 meters from whatever
submitted an agricultural report is less
than 10 meters I've measured it myself
any other questions for the yes Picasso
field can one just point out
visibility's fly he starts at about two
and a half meters deep that one end and
disappears to about one centimeter deep
the other end so there are a number of
trees you have to take down depending on
where they are in the visibilities
flying and I'm not sure we've yet got a
really good answer on that maybe slide
eleven hopefully we can get some clarity
because the color is not shown very well
on them so in the darker blue which we
can see on the screen are shown to be
being category trees and hedges and they
include the root protection areas shown
in red in essentially the middle of the
visibility splay if that's in there
we've got a very pale blue color and
that is shown as the trees hedges to be
removed so that is the difference
between the two so we can see it is just
that yeah it's not very visible on the
screen unfortunately but yeah on the
members papers hopefully that clarifies
exactly where we are talking about
removal from I think so
[Music]
the distance is approximately 60 meters
from the nearest axis thank you sorry
thank you we have no objector and a
supporter or the applicant but we do
have the ward member counsel walk boys
over to you thank you on the site
location plan house number one nine
eight almost directly opposite the
bungalow is a listed building with early
16th century origins it's within sight
of the proposed bridge and it's setting
will be directly affected by the
construction of a bridge and its
associated visibility splay houses two
or three two or four on the end of the
visibility square timber-framed of fact
they're also listed and their setting
will be affected admittedly access to
the bungalow at present is not
straightforward over a single lane brick
bridge with a semicircular arch and low
brick parapet then down the cancer
passing in front of Brook house before
reaching the drive to the bungalow this
access has been allowed to overgrow but
it does exist and could be improved at
present the buildings on the east side
of the street are screened from the road
and this screening act is enormously to
the rural character of thorn among
magnet it is particular significant to
the villages within a special landscape
area and also relevant to the settings
of the three great through two listed
houses from the arboriculture report
although none of the trees has been
identified as worthy of tree
preservation orders they contribute
positively to the overall character of
the locality and are noted as category
82 for their contribution to the mature
leafy character of the street and for
the closure and screening they provide
the walk along the cons is particularly
attractive and their valuables and
amenity resource it is separated from
traffic through the village physically
by the watercourse the river dove and
visually by the diverse mix of
vegetation
the street is at its narrowest at this
point barely room for two cars and
there's a little bit of confusion yet I
think it's the ninety meters display is
from the center of the bridge so that
makes a total of a hundred and eighty
meters of splay that's my reading of it
so 180 meters of visitors visibilities
play along one side wouldn't enhance
visibility but there would also be
another vehicle access point there IG's
existing a small footbridge at least
direct to the bungalow at present this
is discreetly sited amongst the trees
would it be retained and consequently
more visible as a result of the
construction of the additional bridge
further compromised in the setting of
number 198 the scale of the construction
of the bridge is constrained by the
desire not to excessive 8 the periodic
flooding of the street by the river
death
it is however visually a very stark 21st
century intrusion in conclusion the
existing access is perceived as
constraining the potential use of the
bungalow and this proposal of a new
bridge is seen as a solution however
there is also the NPP requirement to
conserve and enhance historic
environment and the cumulative effects
of this development should not be
underestimated this setting of three
listed properties will be adversely
affected as with the unique character of
thorn and magnet within a special
landscape barrier thank you very much
for that
can I just based on what you've raised
I've got a question I'd like to ask the
case officer so we hear about the
special landscape area and we hear about
the listed buildings what is the
heritage you just reconfirmed Heritage's
view in terms of that impact and the
bridge the Heritage Department have
raised no objections in fact it provided
no calm
with regards to the application may also
reiterate that Suffolk County Council
highways haven't raised any objections
to the proposal and may I also note one
more thing with regards to the removal
of the shrub and the trees on site if in
a scenario someone was to remove these
because they are not protected and
they're not situate in the conservation
area it's not resisted by the council
the removal won't be resisted by council
so I just wanted to point this out that
we have no control over that saying that
can be removed whether there's a
planning application or not that's
correct okay so it's not actually
something we could stop as a council
even if they chose to do it tomorrow
without a planning application okay so
the yes even though it's a special
landscape area that doesn't matter and
no it doesn't because first of all the
site doesn't entirely especially the the
location where the bridge is proposed
it's not within the landscape area
special and scope area and I believe in
this scenario if we have some control
over the side it's a better option do
not thank you okay raised yes
councillor Massillon counselor that's
gonna raise more questions thank you
that there's been a lot of talk about
the cancer both from the board member
and the parish meeting representative
I'm assuming that the cancer is the like
parallel track to the road and I'd like
to ask is it a public right-of-way or is
it only private access to the houses
that are on that Street
it is a public right-of-way as as I
understand it there is another further
bridge which has a sign on it which
there's only pedestrian access no
vehicle access to the bungalow so the
three access points to the bungalow one
of which is only pedestrian access and
pedestrian access is all along the
cancer which I think was coughing
translates as Coffee Dwayne so it's an
ancient route through the village house
the field thank you yeah I was just
looking at the list of console tees
notice that the map suggests that this
bridge at certain times will be under
water it floods in this area and I don't
see any response from the highways there
from the county floods team to say
whether that's likely to exacerbate
flooding issues or not thank you no we
haven't had any responses despite
consulting the Environment Agency twice
in fact on two occasions we had
consulted them I did have a chat with
the flood officer and he directed me to
the government's website with regards to
flooding information and as I mentioned
within the report and also presented
just earlier the government flood was
information identified that the risk in
this locality is medium and also that
the chance of flooded with flooding is
between 1 percent to 3.3 percent each
year but is the county not the authority
on those issues in this area that's
correct and that's why we consult them
and we consulted them twice in this
occasion and no objections were provided
no concerns were raised thank you sorry
can I just check because you said you
consulted the Environment Agency twice
what did you consult with Suffolk County
counselors floods team twice that's
correct
you didn't meet with the floods team and
they said they had no comment to the
application it wasn't that they didn't
respond they had no comment they had no
comments I emailed personally Jason
Steele killed him because he's a flood
and water officer and he didn't raise
any objections he did mention the permit
that's not a planning consideration it's
not something that we would be assessing
thank you any other questions at this
point
okay members so we've had all the
information cut the forest is for us to
discuss debate and to come to a
conclusion yes casa milà thank you chair
well having sort of listened to what
everyone's had to say and also sort of
studying the documents yes I accept that
some of the trees etc need to be removed
but apparently none of these have been
identified as worthy tree preservation
orders it's also considered that the
works would not have a significant
adverse impact on the contribution of
the group to the character of the
surroundings and obviously highways have
commented that they raised no objection
to the proposal and it provides adequate
visibility and meets highway standards
and the engineer's specifications etc
provides the proposed design is in
accordance with good practice so if you
have that I'm minded to agree with the
Planning Officers conclusion in support
of this application thank you cancer
eben thank you very much sure I'm
undecided at the moment I'm very
concerned about this because the you
know it's unusual to have such a high
proportion you know a quart of village
objecting to an application and raising
their concerns and is an extremely
narrow the piece of Road when you look
at the Google Maps and the satellite
images in the center of the village and
it's well screened by trees and it's
very rural and this cons and cons are
route I mean I think as well that needs
to be used you know
it needs to be used by vehicles and and
cars as it as it was meant for before it
falls into complete disrepair plus the
fact that you know that to drive to the
bungalow you only have to go past two
houses to get to their bungalow and if
you're coming from the north you come in
that way anyway and if you're coming
from the south you've got a you know do
a u-turn past two houses but I think
just in terms of the rural aspect and
the fact that you know yes I agree they
could take the trees down if they wish
to but I suspect you know it would ruin
the rural character of that that part of
the village but so I'm kind of not
really convinced at the moment on on
this yeah it's a it's a heartstring
versus planning isn't it on this count
Samantha thank you yes yes I too think
that this is is more complex than it
looks at first sight because you know it
is a very rural Lane and it's got a very
you know a lot of trees on that side of
the road now and I think the issue about
the 90 metres I've just worked out by
looking at the plans on a slightly
larger scale there is a 90 meter
visibility display and I think the trees
in the hedge will stay but it is at the
moment or presumably I've got a Google
Streetview picture up there's obviously
a lot of extra growth and that needs
trimming on the verge that will have to
go to create the visibility display but
it is a very rural setting it's a very
narrow road I think I am a bit concerned
about what will come next which
obviously isn't part of this planning
application but there is clearly a
motive to behind this putting this
bridge in and as it stands at the moment
there is I don't see there's any
necessity to put a bridge in and and
there are a lot of objections from the
community it will change the view from
the road and the somebody raised the
flooding issue that it is in a flood
zone but then the existing cancer route
is also within that flood zone so
presumably that doesn't make an awful
lot of difference but I I have my doubts
about the necessity of this at the
moment and I therefore are less inclined
to support it because it's not necessary
and it is going to change the setting
now that whether their planning matters
or not is another another thing but you
know Minh tai don't think the advantages
of it outweigh the loss of the community
a loss of the surround you know the view
of the surroundings so I'm I'm I don't
know where I'm going to go at the moment
but I do have my doubts about it thank
you
I agree that any changes um is hard but
I think there are no planning reasons
that we can stop this they can take the
trees down whether we give them
permission or not and and there are no
significant you know frankly planning
harm that is gonna go on here and and I
think we have to support the officer and
I'm happy to the place that we um agree
with you and go through with this
proposed but council having a councilor
field your next
yes while I recognize that people could
take the trees down I'm not sure they
would be motivated to do that and the
set on a build a bridge
I personally am somewhat concerned by
the flooding issues in the in the
absence of a clear and positive study
from from Jason Skilton when you build
bridge a culvert in fact in this case
across our stream clearly in conditions
of high flow the water tends to back up
or it does if that bridge finishes up
under water and it's quite clear from
the flood map that it would so I have
some concerns about the impact on other
houses that it would will worsen
flooding in the village how much well
without a professional clear statement I
find it difficult to judge so I'm not in
favor of this at this moment
can I just chuck something in I know
it's been already proposed by cancer
having him but there is an option that
we defer it and ask the flood stream for
a full report so that we can actually
base our decision with some floods
guidance because I think the lack of
floods guidance in this area where we
know what's happening we've had no
comment on something that is clearly an
issue so that's another option that we
can put out there cancer having me
but surely I just think there are other
bridges that thought access for all
those other properties which are also in
the flood zone and and so therefore if
jason hasn't come back and said there's
a problem you know why would there be a
problem with flooding with all these
other culverts that are already clearly
there are they upstream or downstream
excuse me from the answer
anyone else wish to speak counsel Miller
Thank You chair I'm happy to second
counselor having him spare anyone else
wish this week you want to come back how
can I describe this before you come back
I mean for me this is a real difficult
one because everything that can see burn
says I agree with but the problem is
none of those are planning reasons and
that's the fundamental problem I've got
is that I hear what the village says and
clearly all their concerns and the and
the the fact that we've had a petition
shows that there is you know huge angst
about this but we here today cannot look
at what may happen in the site after
tomorrow today that would be totally
separate matter nothing to be considered
today we're only here to look at the
bridge and what is before us today so
what may or may not happen in the future
of speculation in irrelevant to this
committee highways or a hundred percent
happy with the application the floods
team have been consult and say they have
no comment so I cannot find a sink and
the Heritage people who actually would
comment about the listed building impact
again have not raised any concerns so
there isn't I can't find one single
planning reason to refuse the
application even though my heart was
very sympathetic to what the parish is
saying we have to only look at planning
reasons at the moment I'm struggling to
find any reasons to refuse this yep
councillor Mayer you an excellent
customers have we had no comment about
the flooding or have they failed to
comment I think it's best for me to
circular to email that receive from
Jason I think our might he hasn't raised
any objections to the proposal he has
replied says there's no objection he has
replied to my personal email not through
the consultation not through the formal
consult
he moved me back to direct me to a few
websites which I have done he has
directed me to the places that could
find further information which regards
to this he has just confirmed it's
within the flood zone which something
that we knew from our mapping it is
within the flood zone 2 & 3 partially
thank you you just can you just tell me
what we're supposed to do because I'm
not heard my so she chose quite properly
chosen their words carefully it he
didn't respond within the consultation
process I'm reading that the officer was
a bit concerned and wanted to make
absolutely sure that it hadn't been
administrator the overlooked so she
quite properly sent a personal email and
got reply back saying indicating that he
had indeed was aware of a consultation
that effectively he had nothing official
to say but directed you to the
government website yeah Cassatt in light
of the declaration of the climate
emergency in biodiversity emergencies
anything that's not a planning
consideration it's nothing it's not a
planning matter it's only planning as we
work through the training that we've had
counts sir ma'am sir thank you I'm just
looking at page 22 of our papers and in
paragraph ten point three it says that
the prose bridge by virtue of its nature
scale and style is not considered to
unduly erode the amenity enjoyed by the
neighboring properties the very fact
that we've had a petition presumably
signed by many of the occupants of the
neighboring properties perhaps eroding
in may amenity enjoyed is a subjective
matter and the neighboring the occupiers
of the neighboring properties obviously
feel that it is going to
erode their immunity it's subjective
therefore it's not as clear-cut you
can't just say oh it's not going to
because they're obviously concerned that
there is going to be some harm and it's
all I'm saying is it's very subjective
and that is related the office view on
that whose britainís let's just see what
they're saying yeah thank you yes and
that's why I assess it is not
significantly so there will be some
impact however not significant enough to
want a refusal thank you
but but all I'm saying I'm just trying
to say that that the officer feels it's
insignificant properties the neighboring
owners that's the same with every other
yeah I know obviously think it is
significant because they've gone to the
trouble of doing a petition so you know
you could argue that in someone's eyes
it is significant I'm fearful that might
give you a reason for yeah customer so
that's what we do with every application
we weigh up we have to weigh up the harm
the subjective argument the officer has
come to one decision there's nothing to
stop us coming to another decision
because it's a subjective argument it's
on that particular item it's subjective
yes but not on the other points count
Samantha I'm really sorry even um thank
you - I think you'd look at policies
protecting existing personal immunity
would be will be one and development
appropriate to setting and I would I'm
concerned the heritage team haven't
responded to this consultation either
although the the comment is a double
negative in the report which implies
that it is them a significant arm - they
I'm great here listed buildings I'm sure
that's not what the officer means but
but yes no I think it it could be you
know those are those are factors that
could and I just again I just say I am
concerned that you know the people that
live in this area
living there because of its intensive
rural setting and therefore protecting
their existing that residential immunity
could be a reason here thank you well we
we have a proposal and a seconder based
on what happens with that let's see what
happens with that vote first then yeah
absolute thanks I think a lot of the
people who signed the petition I'm much
more worried about the potential
development factor behind this which
we're not here to look at today I think
all those people that sign that thing
have been told or they're going to
develop it they're gonna put house in
there which you know who knows if that's
true but this is not what we're looking
at today and I think that's what most
people will be worried about the future
which we're not here to discuss today so
it's been proposed and seconded by
Councillor had hang on a second by
councilor mother as per the
recommendation all those in favor of the
recommendation to have a show of hands
biz to those against and abstentions I
would like to put a proposal forward
that we defer this application and asked
for a report from the Heritage team and
we asked for a report from the floods
team that comes back with it to help us
make a more informed decision do I have
a seconder councilor field anyone wish
to speak on that
all those in favor
bears against one abstention one okay so
it is deferred and it will come back
with more information
okay thank you very much the next item
on the agenda is DC 1906 for seven land
off Green Road Woolpit
and Alex is to present the application
and council it burns just gonna leave
and count some answers going to move
over there you're more than welcome to
stay as you wish or leave as you wish
[Laughter]
okay Alex over to you
Thank You Gemma members this is
application reference DC 19 double zero
six four seven and the application
proposes amendment to the design and
layout of 49 dwellings and garages and
cart lodges on land to the east side of
Green Road in in Woolpit the host
planning application reference to double
1/2 forward slash 16 was refused by the
council's refer referrals committee in
September 2017 however it was own
appealed and the Planning Inspectorate
sought to grant Planning Commission in
September 2018 and the relevant papers
are provided in the bundle for your your
reference under the presentation this is
the location of the proposal site edged
in red for you there the south of the
village and an aerial map of closer in
the constraints the major constraint is
it's the public footpath which runs
along the eastern boundary of the site
acting into the existing estate roads
here we also have a listed building here
at Priory cottage and not shown is
another Lister building which is just
off the road there's a major constraints
FLE this is the site location plan
submitted with the application and this
is just for comparison excuse me we have
the layout approved by the inspector on
the left-hand side and what is currently
proposed on the on the right-hand side
now
what is proposed is in our view not
significant there are a few minor
changes to locations of dwellings most
significantly the swelling in the
corners site however it does push it a
little bit further away from this
southern boundary and these dwellings
are moving forward a little bit here
this dwelling a little bit further to
the corner and you will notice the size
of the garages a little bit larger and
being set or back in the site
particularly in this location with the
the major scale and form of the
buildings it's not it's not changing and
the affordable dwellings are not
changing at all those so just the
confirmation that is what is now
proposed vision K and zooming in on the
North section and southern section plea
and these well this is the most
significant change I believe to be
proposed so what we have for you is on
the left-hand side what was approved by
the inspector on the right-hand side
what is now proposed so we had formerly
carte logis with one car parking space
and storage what it's not proposed is a
little bit larger full fully enclosed
garages with two car parking spaces and
there in accordance with advisory
parking standards by Suffolk County
Council highways they thought they could
be used for parking spaces and other new
garages proposed this larger garage only
one parking space with quite a bit of
storage there are two of those proposed
on the site and
as the remainder will be single garages
again in accordance with caddy highways
parking standards so they could
potentially be used as parking spaces
and then on to what is changing in terms
of the proposed elevations on the on the
right as I go through is what's been
approved and sorry on the left is what's
been approved on the right is what isn't
I proposed
it's okay so what the difference really
the scammer form not changing just a
little bit in terms of fenestration or
layout design well yes of course Jack
yeah the projecting window in this
location is being removed that is no
flush they removing sections of boarding
from the front and rear elevations the
rear window is now being changed to a
rear door to allow rear access and the
the side elevation window just a little
bit smaller in this location that's
really it
internal layout again very minor
alterations in terms of the bathroom and
internal cupboards nothing really
significant and then there's that
external door which I mentioned earlier
giving access that's a common theme
throughout and I'll just briefly go
through those well you know that's house
type two again minor elevational changes
there and again internal layout
in significant changes I'd say internal
cupboards bathroom main changes there
these are the elevations which are not
proposing the only ones which are
proposing and that's one of the
affordable terraces this is the
affordable terrace which is proposed to
to change the scale and form will remain
the same however variations in Windows
I've got a narrow window as proposed and
again rear access patio doors proposed
with the windows which were an open
access to the rear gardens proposed then
shown on the on the layout I think I
think that's the only change on that
particular one and this is has type four
so a window actually being removed from
the side elevation of this one boarding
being removed rear access doors a
smaller window side apologies for this
Victor going through this with this
fine-tooth comb
this is hashed time house type 5.1 and
you can see window types changing
scaling form remaining as approved and
the rear access doors there this is 5.2
just the same internal layout but just a
different roof design
again minimal changes just the rear
access door on that one and proposal
they act just the main not changing
that's type six again the windows major
change us there or access door and be
proposed layout change in the staircase
post type seven minimal changes there
it's the rear access door
shown on the proposed floor plans as
well and house type 8.1 which at the
flats 8.2 again flats
and the floor plans this has type nine
and again the floor plans changes and
the strict scene and boundary elevations
as proposed and this has changed in
significantly from what the inspectors
approved we think no significant impact
on landscape setting settings of list of
buildings in fact as I've shown on the
layout one of the dwellings was actually
being moved further away from the
southern boundary and again the other
elevations across the landscape and
street scene and the photographs this is
from the the south southwest corner of
the site looking up green road and
moving around to the right from that
last slide and the site boundary would
square off the field in that location
that's probably better so no further
than that existing dwelling there and
this is the listed building at Priory
cottage directly across Green Road from
the site and the list of building across
the field to the South Range farm
they're looking across the road in the
opposite direction existing dwellings in
the distance and this is the existing
footpath to the rear of dwellings to the
east and screengrabs showing you the
approach into all pit I conclusive
presentation as per your papers officer
recommendation for approval thank you
now it's ask question and often when
changes this and if it was a smaller
number of houses and the changes were
happening would it come back to
committee because often you can make
when you see it the whole time I see
stuffing out the wars we represent you
get and that something this come through
and says minor minor changes to the
application is this just because of the
scale that is having to come back here
yes it's over 15 dwellings they are
changes which are both what could be
considered non material there was a full
section 73 application scheme scheme of
delegation over 15 it needed to come
back I did check that yes it's no case
thank you yeah that's hot
thank you um I know it's by the by Alex
because they've been approved anyway but
on house type 1 2 & 3 & 4 what are the
materials of the walls they're not going
to be grounding
buf bricks any questions at this point
yeah customer yeah Alex it says in here
that octave additional design items have
been including comprising refuge
recycling points and electric vehicle
charging infrastructure do know how many
electrical charging points there are
going to be for vehicles on this yes
that is proposed by way of conditions if
something was assessed already actually
in the discharge of the conditions
application and that will be within all
the proposed garages would have electric
charge evolution we don't have anyone
from the parish counselor we didn't have
an address but we have the applicant
Leslie short if you'd like to come up
and again at two three minutes please
good morning members of the committee
I'm Leslie short from artists and
planning and I represent the applicants
land ex the developer of this site the
application before you today has been
with the council since February the 8th
during which time its contents have not
been the subject of substantive
objection the proposal and assessment of
it is neatly summarized in paragraph six
point one of your office's report the
changes to the design a minor
inconsequential and have no adverse
impact and so I trust that you too will
find them acceptable thank you
corruption a questions thank you very
much I think that's the shortest
presentation say we move on to the two
board members we have councillor Sarah
Mansell and councillor Helen deep we
counselor Mansur over to you thank you
now despite this being a controversial
and unpopular development within Whoopi
itself these as has been said several
times already these are only minor
changes and in fact I think the most
significant changes appear it was a case
of spot the difference on the diagrams
that the major changes to the garage
iing seems to be in the corner that's
furthest away from any existing
properties so I can't really see that
it's going to cause any issues and the
odd bathroom door seems to be opening
the opposite way not quite sure what
what significance that's got you could
actually argue that that changing a
single cart Lodge into a double garage
is a benefit because you're getting an
extra parking space and the fact that
they're going to have electric charging
points is a bonus as well so I really
can't see any problems with this and I'm
actually I actually when I read the
papers assumed that this had been bought
to committee because it is such a
controversial site and there have been
some errors made on on the conditions
which are not relevant to this
application at all but I thought perhaps
that's why it's been brought to
committee because there's been so much
publicity and issues raised about it
before but in this particular
application very no objections and I
currently see it's causing it a lot of
problem very much and have you heard
counsel of geek no I don't think she's
got any anything further to say any a
further comments or objections or
anything
thank you okay any questions for the
ward member no members over to us to
discuss debate and come to a decision
[Music]
now so having um I think I'm gonna agree
with it everything that's been said
there very minor they've got little
effect on the design and so I'm happy to
propose we go along with the officers
recommendation of who this similar thank
you chair I'm happy to second counselor
having himself that we actually agree
with it and go with the office right
anyone else wish to comment before we
get to vote all those in favor that's
unanimous thank you very much
[Applause]
there is a new site inspections no other
Asian business so we closed the meeting
at 10:40 thank you very much